[Music]
foreign
if you could admit to whatever like
extent you're comfortable about that
would just take it I guess it's just
like take us through take us through
that night and like as as yeah no I I
got you so so bottom line is it was I
just got back from Oklahoma I was I was
out there helping out uh I'm a defense
contractor still too so we have the
brewery I do uh I work for a defense
contractor at Fort Carson we still train
soldiers uh getting ready to go that has
been my to me my Saving Grace because it
keeps me with soldiers it keeps me with
vets all of us are vets that are doing
it so we all can kind of work through
our [__] together
um and then you know Joe's still getting
something out of us you know we're done
but at least you know hey here's some
tips of what the [__] I did and and so
that's what we we do when we we help
them uh in the instruction
so I was at Fort Sill with my buddy and
just drove back I got a [__] ticket
on the way back right so I was pissed it
was Friday and I'm like
[__] okay whatever man and it pissed me
off because we got pulled over twice my
buddy uh Wayne he's a he's a skater kid
but he was an Army the same thing he
retired he was a skater kid out of uh
Detroit and Arizona so we get we
understand it because I'm a kid San
Diego skater's all over the [__]
place yeah so I he's a little punk rock
kid and I used to hang out with those
dudes so I understand we get along
really well and he's like you know how
you know it is skater punks hate [__]
cops I [__] can't stand cops because
I I was in the you know parking lot with
my shirt up [__] dude I'm running the
gang [__] you you're all that [__] so
I'm like all right so I'm driving back
from Tech I'm in Texas and this [__]
[__] pulls up to me he's like you
know I should [__] arrest you right
now and I'm like what the [__] did I do
I'm driving fast on an empty road and
who the [__] cares right give me my
[__] ticket I'm like sorry I didn't
realize it give me the ticket he's all
[__] you know get into my [__] and
Wayne's starting to get pissed and I'm
like listen dude you can get mad at him
I can't I [__] get mad at this dude
I'm going to jail right now yeah yeah so
so that was the whole [__] coming
home so I'm amped up and then I told my
wife about it she's like look tomorrow
we'll go out uh we haven't hung out with
chip and Joanne everybody had gone
through this rotation of [__] covid
prior to that like the second round sure
so we hadn't seen him in about a month
and then uh Ray had just got over it too
and so Cassie and Cassie said well let's
all go to dinner
um and Jess goes well let's go to this
this it's uh West Side Cantina uh in
Colorado Springs and they're good folks
they're really good folks
um nice Taco Shop [__] you know
pretty new they wanted to put Justice
beer on tap nice so we went over there
to kind of do that and then check dinner
right sure so it was all six of them we
met up chip and Joanne were there
already with Ray so these are your
friends is your daughter her her
boyfriend in six years they went to prom
together and so look I met Jess in 92.
I got married in when I was 22 to her
so my daughter had been with this guy
for six years she's 22 now wow so her
thought process and again like and and
it it's to me it's funny because I I
never we never really talk about it but
I I told my wife all the time Grace
Grace literally me he's just you know
he's trying to figure it out you know he
was he's a good kid you know he's
getting in trouble but he's not he's
just kind of figuring it out he didn't
do it on the military but he was kind of
figuring it out yeah
and I go we got married at 22. yeah
she's 22. God knows what was going
through her head with her girlfriends
about you know hey you may have proposed
whatever they've been together that long
yeah and and so I've I've referenced him
as my son-in-law for a lot of [__] and I
and I told Cassie you know what's funny
is in the Army when you die when you get
killed in combat they they posthumously
promote you so you were E4 you're you're
gonna get buried as an E5 uh if you were
in E6 you're gonna get buried as an E7
if they can do that they'll do it
my [__] was like yo this could have been
my son-in-law I'm promoting you right
and I did it without even thinking about
it I just kind of said it and then I I
told Cass one day I was like yeah that's
what we do in the Army and she's like oh
[__] and so we it's just been weird how
[__] kind of has been connected
um so we all were at this dinner I'm
going back to this [__]
the tacos he [__] loves tacos so he
was eating and I was joking with so the
running joke with me Ray was hey bro
when I'm gone
[__] shovel the [__] snow right
right I'm a [__] old man I'm tired of
Chevrolet I got my wife and my daughter
they don't [__] touch the shovel so
Ray was like oh [__] scared so that
was our running thing and so while I was
in Oklahoma guess what happened [__]
snow yeah and I and so I get to the
[__] restaurant I look at Ray I go
yeah I got a problem with you he goes oh
hey first before you start
I think he goes he goes there's some
[__] uh there's some juicer there's
some tea going on around here what the
[__] are you talking about Ray doesn't
talk to me a lot because I'm his [__]
girlfriend's death right so he's always
trying to be respectful and [__] and he
doesn't want to [__] start with me
because he knows I'll [__] go in so
he's like all right and I'm like why the
[__] are you talking like this you're
like you're like really chatty and he
was like hey there's some tea Joanne and
Jess are gonna fight and I go what what
the [__] are you talking about who's
just starting [__] and I go listen guy I
got a problem with you I don't know
about them but I got a problem with you
I came home and it's [__] snow on my
driveway he's like but your daughter he
goes Cassie was there and Jess I wasn't
even staying there
I don't give a [__] anymore yeah you've
been here for six years you [__] do
the snow and so that was that was when
we just we just met up and I was but we
were [__] laughing and then he's
ordering all this [__] and [__] tacos
shrimp tacos [__] Margarita that and
I'm I go when the [__] are you gonna
[__] pay for all this [__] he goes no
no I'm good I'll pick him and Cassie's
like shut up Dad and I'm like all right
[__] whatever I'm fine I'm buying so we
had a great night we were all the the
owner giving us a few shots we were just
[__] hanging out great time great
food my daughter goes hey we Wyatt her
best friend from second grade
um he's now potted plant he's uh he does
drag
um he'd known her since she got to
Carson uh in 07. first day second grade
they walked into class together became
best friends
that kid stayed with my daughter the
whole time she was going through this
[__] with me and my son and [__]
deployments all this [__] her Wyatt
still best friends
she said hey why it's birthdays today
he's performing he's doing his drag show
and I'm like [__] it let's go we're
going so we were gonna go and and so we
all got our [__] we went to the next
place which was Club Q
um we went in there and me and my wife
got there first
um and we were like well what the [__]
man nobody's here we you know we drove
out somewhere like all right listen we
sat down and I I literally I told her
hey because she my wife went so the the
the stage if this is the stage we were
in the corner there's like a little ramp
right here to the entrance and she went
right to this corner corner table and I
go babe I don't I don't I don't like
because I don't like having my back to
the [__] entrance at all it's like
what about the booth over here she's
like it wasn't a booth it was more like
a a long uh bench seating along a wall
and tables like you get in restaurants
you know I'm saying the long bench so I
was like why don't we sit over there
she's like no no I want to be on by the
stage because why is performing I want
to be right there
I've never seen this kind of [__] so I
didn't know they were you know you got a
tip and all this other [__] so it was
like it was [__] cool
we're in there and having a great time
performers were [__] hilarious
they're doing their thing they were
[__] having a great time uh Wyatt was
awesome and then there was this couple
uh dudes sitting to the right of me and
they had this fan it was making this
clacking noise and instead of clapping
they were making this
and I kept telling my wife and go I want
that [__] thing for the soccer game
or for football I go I want I want that
[__] noise maker I love that [__] I
got drums and all this [__] because I'm
in when I get into my sports I'm in
right yeah so I'm like that clacker [__]
I want that it's pretty crowded in there
I mean it wasn't it wasn't packed right
but it was it was a full room right and
then uh the show ended we were having a
great time we were still raining and had
bought everybody a shot of jealous my
wife has a video of US 20 minutes before
this thing all of us cheers and just the
biggest Smiles you ever seen on all of
us and in the background of those two
guys with the clacker they're right
there behind us and I laughed because
they actually came to visit us at the
brewery and and I go where the [__] were
you guys because they they just wanted
to meet us and I go yeah where were you
guys at he's like yeah we were on the
booth on the side I go did you have the
fan yeah yeah he's like yeah that's me
like dude we were talking about you the
whole [__] night wow and he's like
she he went into his car pulled the fan
out gave me the [__] [__] yeah and so
now it's in the front of the brewery
when you walk in this Pride uh Pride uh
fan beautiful because it was it was like
that was
it's weird how people are connected and
you didn't even know it right like I was
like into this [__] this guy's like he
got [__] shot through his [__]
neck but he's walking around and I'm
like are you [__] kidding there
there's some every one of these people
in there had a hero story regardless
where they're hiding where they're
[__] jumping diving I don't give a
[__]
19 people or 17 19 people got shot five
people got killed so you do the math
there's more than 30 rounds in that
guy's magazine so that's that's all I'm
gonna say you don't shoot that many
people with [__] 30 rounds you don't
so
but again I don't know the details of
all this [__] I just know what they put
out which is just a picture of him
walking in which is the same visual that
I had when I saw him and I took to the
ground so when I took the ground with
chip I already had said that you know
are you [__] kidding me and I think
that's when I went into mode and I I
call it combat mode which is because
it's at that point you'd stop thinking
you're about managing the chaos it's
about managing chaos as an officer
that's your job as a leader does your
head go first to to your wife or do you
know like no no it was just like deal
with it listen I everybody couldn't even
shot around me I had no [__] idea all
I knew is this guy's in here still
shooting
I have to stop it because if I don't
he's gonna kill all of us right like
there's no you can't think about who's
already shot because he's still shooting
so I I I I literally as I hit the ground
I kind of I try to get back up and I
slipped and I don't know whether it was
chips I don't know and I told you I have
no idea but I slipped and I fell back
into that booth that I was talking about
that I wanted to sit at so I hit my back
and I was like [__] because my back's
already garbage I'm an old man and
[__] Army [__] didn't help so I hit
my back and I'm I'm looking and across
the room like as you look at those those
two doors it was a glass door like any
other store with a bar in the middle
that goes out to The Patio sure and I
saw that dude just like where that guy
is right now
facing out
um and he's had armor on so that's the
[__] so I went across it and I
got into him
so personally I don't remember fighting
him standing up and and this video all
this [__] and apparently I was fighting
him standing up and then um we ended up
on the ground and so but Thomas James
had jumped at him uh in it from the
front
I got to him from the pack so Thomas got
to him and Thomas got hurt I don't want
to say well how that's up to him to talk
about but he was hurt pretty bad
I didn't know this I didn't even know he
was fighting anybody so as we got there
it was kind of like he was starting to
fight and then I got there I'm trying to
figure out what the [__] is going on so
we start fighting standing up trying to
get this guy to whatever and I'm pretty
sure Thomas was just hanging onto his
rifle at that point and that's what kind
of brought him down we all kind of went
down with him
um
six [__] minutes you you did the
boxing movies and [__] three minutes of
[__] boxing no joke I'm a fat [__]
guy right six minutes of [__] balls
to the wall I have to kill this dude
it was nuts right
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we are
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
[Music]